all right let's talk Britney Spears now
because she is about to blow the roof
off the circus that is her life story
E.T has learned Britney's new book is
close to being finished and she's not
holding back yeah it's been a roller
coaster the pop star reportedly got 15
million dollars for the deal and yeah
there's a lot to dig into
from JT to Sam asgari and the two
marriages in between those breakdowns
and of course the dramatic end of her
13-year conservatorship
says Britney pushed herself even more to
finish after little sister Jamie Lynn
spoke out in January of last year how
did Brittany and Justin's breakup affect
you I was so sad
we're told Britney's written a few
versions but is getting some help from a
Ghost Rider his name is Sam Lansky the
journalist has profiled Madonna Adele
and Taylor Swift he's also written about
his personal recovery from drugs and
alcohol I was 17 years old and had been
subsisting on a diet of cigarettes and
Adderall for months
Britney's been spending most of her time
at home lately but nothing compared to
actor Jack Nicholson he was just spotted
for the first time in 18 months this is
new video of the 85 year old Oscar
winner stepping out on the porch of his
Beverly Hills Home Jack looked casual
and comfy as he enjoyed a little sun he
was last seen in 2021 wearing a mask and
watching the Lakers with his youngest
son
let's move on to an E.T exclusive
Vanderpump rule star Raquel leves has
checked into a mental health treatment
facility I kind of did a deep dive and
really opened myself up our source says
Raquel who's been at the center of the
cheating scandal had planned to admit
herself before the show taped its
reunion special but her rep says she
waited so she could finish her filming
commitment we're told Bravo is
supportive and Raquel's program is not
related to substance abuse issues
[Music]